everybody we are back
my next guest is a talented comedian who
can be seen on john oliver's new york
stand-up show airing this thursday at
midnight on comedy central please
welcome the very funny pete holmes
yeah okay
that was exciting uh
how's it going everybody
yeah
okay i'm a little i want to get this out
of the way right up top i'm not a cool
person
i don't know if you can uh
tell already from my overall vibe
i don't know if this is going to make
sense but i'm 31 years old i don't have
any kids but i'm already kind of like a
fun dad
can you get that sense for me just like
the dorky dad at a barbecue
fresca that guy
singing hip-hop wrong to children just
like i'll say you can have whatever you
need yeah
snacks on dad patron no patron
fun dad
like i don't have kids but if i did i'd
be the kind of dad they're having a
sleepover i'd keep barging and
embarrassing them with the tray of food
just like tuna melts dad's style
that's extra mayo
if you like it then you should put some
cheese on it if you
get out of here chad
if you like it then you shouldn't put
your feet on it
seriously kyle the ottoman is decorative
so
you didn't know you didn't know
fun dab
so i don't trust adults who eat candy is
that something we can talk about
it's one of my favorite things to talk
about adults that eat silly candy i was
landing here at lax one time and in my
row there was a woman that had to be in
her late 70s and to celebrate landing
safely she reached into her purse and
took out an atomic fireball
just like oh yeah
spicy cinnamon candy yeah mama did good
today
just immediately i want to be like stop
it it's not for you i want to chase you
with a broom
eating silly candy and being a grown
person those things are at odds with
each other yet every time i go home my
dad has grown ass friends that talk to
me like hey pete pete opening a thing a
fun dip
marriage is hard man it's hard
yeah it's not 50 50. it's 100 100 you
know what i mean
you got to recommit to that person every
single day
she's my best friend but she's also my
lover you know what i mean
raises the kids but keep that stuff out
of the bedroom
angels and [ __ ] man
yeah i've been tempted
mostly emotional stuff nothing physical
there was a woman at work kathy i don't
know
she just connected with me in a way that
meredith never did
would go to lunch would write it off
would say it was for work but no
she saw a hole in me it's right after
the miscarriage and i
ring pop
it's the hardest time of my life
the joke is doing it as long as i can
that's
so i have an eye telephone i have an i
telephone
thank you
which means i have google on my phone
i'm guessing a lot of you do have google
on my phone now it's ruining our lives
i don't know if you've noticed it's
ruining life
because we know
everything
but we're not a lick smarter for it we
just know
you don't know something
wait
two seconds
you will know
having google on your phone is like
having a drunk know-it-all in your
pocket
there's no time for mystery or wonder
you're just like
how do they make glass yeah
and you know
but the time between not knowing and
knowing is so brief
that knowing feels exactly like not
knowing
so life is meaningless
i've literally been in bed in the
morning alone just like
where's tom petty from
but i feel nothing because there was no
time to not know
listen to me there was a time and i
don't mean to get all andy rooney on ya
but there was a time that if you didn't
know where tom petty was from you just
didn't know
and you felt that yearning and that
deficit in your being and you'd go
around and ask actual people
like where's tom petty from i don't know
i don't know i don't know and now i'm
impregnated with wonder and then they go
and ask people
until one fateful day you see a girl
wearing a heartbreakers t-shirt you rush
up to her and you're like hey where's
tom petty from and she tells you florida
and a wave of endorphins and pleasure
and meaning would wash over you and you
felt something and that's how you met
your wife do you understand
your wedding song was refugee
did bizlaff thank you very much
everybody good night thank you
that's great that was hilarious thank
you so much hilarious pete holmes
everybody
thank you that was our show want to
thank all my guests sarah silverman biz
stone we got andy richter jimmy dean on
the base of cable band stay tuned for a
little press tonight with his guest mike
tyson we'll see you tomorrow bye